ich war neulich im flughafen in der
lounge und da hat tatsächlich jemand auf
dem klo telefoniert wie ist das
angerufen zu werden
plötzlich ertönt eine spülung eins
meiner logos ist unpünktlichkeit was ich
schrecklich finde leute die kein oder zu
wenig trinkgeld geben
öner kebab im tram essen finde ich
unmöglich also wir haben verschiedene
manieren bücher geprüft axel hacke über
den anstand in schwierigen zeiten und
die frage wie wir miteinander umgehen
und dann haben wir noch den alexander
von schönburg die kunst des lässigen
anstands also lustigerweise operieren ja
beide bücher mit dem wort ritterlichkeit
ja das hat mir dann wieder sehr gefallen
weil ich finde da ist vieles tatsächlich
angelegt von unseren vorstellungen was
anstand und manieren betrifft ich weiß
nicht wie du das siehst aber für mich
ist hakim er eine eine art von es ist
auch nicht so auf regeln runter geplant
was nicht mehr verlassen hat soll es
geht mir um deine haltung zum beispiel
sei es doch selbstverständlich dass man
der frau die tür aufhalten
der punkt ist gar nicht diese diskussion
ist das jetzt dann wieder so eine art
von sozusagen strukturen küss die hand
sexismus wenn man einer frau die tür
aufhält und ich finde das nett wenn man
leuten die tür aufhält egal welches
geschlecht jetzt diese person hat die
man es auch nicht die für die tür
aufhalten das einfach doch eine nette
geste ich finde es schon schön wenn man
zum beispiel von seiner besseren hälfte
hingewiesen wird auf moment wo man sich
vielleicht nicht perfekt benommen hat
und das wird ihr sicher gibt andauern
ich weiß das zu schätzen weil ich weiss
das geschieht nicht irgendwie um mich zu
kritisieren aber im sinne von die kunst
des lässigen anstands die gestaltung des
covers liegt bereits eine sichtweise von
manieren nahe die rolltreppe geht nach
oben wie findest du die sichtweise von
manieren als vehikel zum sozialen
aufstieg das ist einfach etwas was mich
langweilt ehrlich gesagt natürlich kann
man so anständig wie möglich erzogen
sein und alle regeln kennen
aber wenn man mit dem herzen nicht beim
anderen ist dann ist das auch egal also
der atomkritiker hat mal eine art von
professionellen anstand und
professioneller anstand heißt dafür
dass man die kritik professionell äußert
und dann bin ich schon dafür dass man
das sehr deutlich sagen was merken wir
uns wir merken uns händewaschen bitte
danke sagen
im öffentlichen raum wenn es geht leise
telefonieren und sowieso gar nicht auf
der toilette nicolas steiner elik sollen
und in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
nicht rauchen trinken schuhe aus die
löhner essen und schuhe ausziehen
[Musik]